en este vídeo hablaremos con mayor
detalle sobre la noción de los mercados
de competencia perfecta vamos a pensar
en cuáles escenarios puede una empresa
tener una ganancia o una pérdida
económica como repaso los mercados de
competencia perfecta son un ideal
teórico existen pocos mercados en el
mundo real que se acerquen realmente a
la competencia perfecta algunos pueden
acercarse pero la mayoría de los
mercados se encuentran dentro del
espectro entre mercados de competencia
perfecta y el otro extremo digamos los
monopolios pero aquí hablamos de
competencia perfecta y en la competencia
perfecta los productos de las empresas
no están diferenciados son homogéneos no
hay barreras para entrar o salir del
mercado por lo que en esa situación las
curvas de oferta y demanda del mercado
determinan el precio del mercado lo que
también define el ingreso marginal para
estas empresas todas son precio
aceptantes todas son pasivas con
respecto al precio cualquiera que sea el
precio del mercado ese será el precio al
que las empresas venderán sus productos
así que la decisión de las empresas es
qué cantidad producir y vender o cuándo
entrar o salir del mercado veamos esto
con más detalle estas son curvas de
oferta y demanda que pueden encontrarse
en cualquier mercado las primeras
unidades del producto generan una gran
ganancia marginal porque las personas
están dispuestas a pagar mucho por esas
primeras unidades pero después la
ganancia marginal disminuye con cada
unidad incremental y es por eso que
vemos esta demanda con pendiente
descendente y en la curva de la oferta
la primera unidad en el mercado va a ser
muy barata de producir pero después el
costo marginal va a aumentar y donde se
encuentran estas curvas el punto donde
se encuentran las curvas de la oferta y
la demanda es donde se ubica el precio
de equilibrio y la cantidad de
equilibrio del mercado podemos mostrar
esto con esta línea que nos dice que el
precio de equilibrio es de 10 pesos y
como mencioné antes este va a ser el
precio al que todas las empresas tendrán
que vender sus productos y quizá éstas
no sean todas las empresas que existen
en el mercado
en un mercado de competencia perfecta
todas las empresas de ese mercado tienen
que aceptar ese precio pensando en esto
qué cantidad deben producir las empresas
ab y c
cuál de estas empresas tendrá ganancias
y cuál no los invito a que pausa en el
vídeo y traten de responder a ambas
preguntas o quizás solo responder cuál
de estas empresas tendrá una ganancia y
me refiero a una ganancia económica en
este contexto muy bien vamos a analizar
primero a la empresa para cualquier
empresa no es racional producir una
cantidad en donde el costo marginal sea
mayor que el ingreso marginal como es el
caso de esta empresa recuerden que esta
recta de acá que es la recta del precio
es también el ingreso marginal por lo
que para una unidad extra si no puede
venderse en un precio mayor al costo de
producirla no se debe producir una
unidad extra es racional para las
empresas producir más mientras
incrementa el costo marginal hasta
llegar al punto en el que el costo
marginal es igual al ingreso marginal
que
igual al precio del mercado que es el
que tienen que aceptar es racional para
esta empresa producir esta cantidad de
aquí esta es la cantidad para esta
empresa esta empresa será lucrativa o no
veamos en esta cantidad cuál es el costo
total promedio el costo total promedio
se encuentra aquí por lo que para cada
unidad se tiene esta diferencia entre el
precio o el ingreso marginal y su costo
total promedio una forma de pensar en la
ganancia de esta empresa hablando de
ganancia económica es como el área de
este rectángulo digamos que si el costo
total promedio en esa cantidad es de 8
pesos entonces la altura del rectángulo
es de 10 menos 8 que es 2 pesos y la
base es la cantidad de unidades
producidas por la empresa digamos que la
cantidad producida por esta empresa es
de 10 mil unidades por año el área del
rectángulo es igual a 2 pesos por 10 mil
unidades lo que es 20 mil pesos por
periodo de tiempo si esto es por año
ahora analicemos a la empresa ve usando
la misma lógica la empresa
tiene o no ganancia económica bueno la
empresa ve también es precio aceptante
por lo que el precio de equilibrio es el
precio que esa empresa tiene que aceptar
y también en su curva de ingreso
marginal y es por eso que es una curva
plana ya que no importa qué cantidad
produzcan las empresas todas tendrán el
mismo precio y no sería racional para
ellos producir una cantidad en donde su
costo marginal sea mayor que el ingreso
marginal por lo que van a producir esta
cantidad y cuál será la ganancia
económica en esta cantidad esta es la
cantidad de la segunda empresa o empresa
ve esta otra es la empresa y las
cantidades se parecen digamos que esta
es de 9 mil 500 unidades por periodo de
tiempo en este caso el costo total
promedio en esa cantidad es igual al
costo marginal por lo que también es
igual al ingreso marginal en esa
cantidad los 10 pesos que reciben por
unidad también serán los 10 pesos en
promedio que gastan en producir esa
unidad otra forma de pensar en esto es
que el área de este rectángulo es cero
porque no tiene altura en este caso la
empresa ve tiene cero ganancia económica
y por último pero no menos importante
analicemos a la empresa se pausa en el
vídeo y piensen en cuál será la ganancia
económica de la empresa c bueno como
hemos visto es racional para la empresa
se producir la cantidad en donde el
costo marginal iguala al ingreso
marginal que es igual al precio del
mercado por lo que produce esta cantidad
de aquí y digamos que esa cantidad son
nueve mil unidades cuál es el costo
total promedio para esa cantidad en
nueve mil unidades el costo total
promedio es de 12 pesos
cuál es su ganancia económica por cada
unidad que vende recibe 10 pesos y en
promedio le cuesta 12 pesos producir esa
unidad por lo que tiene una pérdida
económica de 2 pesos por unidad esta
altura es de 2 pesos multiplicada por
las unidades que son 9 mil son 18 mil
pesos no de ganancia económica sino de
pérdida económica una cosa que debemos
pensar es porque cualquier empresa
tendría que estar en esta situación es
importante pensar en las cosas a corto
plazo
y a largo plazo a corto plazo hablamos
de este análisis que acabamos de hacer
en donde una empresa racional decide qué
cantidad producir sus costos fijos están
fijos a corto plazo ya lo hemos
mencionado varias veces en vídeos
anteriores pero a largo plazo los costos
fijos no están fijos por lo que la
empresa puede decidir entrar o salir del
mercado por lo que para la empresa se
aún cuando ya tienen estos costos fijos
es racional para ellos hacer esto porque
así pueden aprovechar el ingreso
marginal que tienen hasta esa cantidad
para cubrir al menos este costo marginal
y también hacerse cargo de algunos de
los costos fijos pero aún así no pueden
tener una ganancia económica a largo
plazo no es razonable para esta empresa
seguir en el mercado es probable que
salgan del mercado